eighteen years more than four thousand
american lives a war that divided one
country devastated another
but in just one moment at the white
house the president
called for an end to u.s combat missions
in iraq
our role in iraq will be
as a dealing with
not it's just
to be available to continue to train to
assist
to help and to deal with isis as
it arrives the iraqi prime minister says
u.s troops are no longer needed to fight
their battles
but their expertise and their support is
american they help iraq
together we fight and feed
isis and i'd like to thank
the american people on behalf of all
iraqis people
george w bush launched the war in iraq
the assault in baghdad brought shock and
awe a deadly attack aimed at removing
saddam hussein from power
he had weapons of mass destruction was
the argument none were ever found
george bush declared mission
accomplished in may 2003
it wasn't the fighting continued more
american lives more iraqi lives were
lost
isil grew in strength in the area a new
enemy
a new challenge a new fight donald trump
pushed hard against isil
cutting its land killing its leadership
reducing its influence
and then he cut troop numbers to 2500
isil remains a threat the group killed
30 people when it bombed the baghdad
market last week
joe biden's decision on combat missions
i mean the us
won't be leaving but it's clear its
priorities lie elsewhere
i don't think any plausible reasonable
policy goal is ever going to be
achievable by this crazy invasion
and so it's it's a matter of trying to
find
a reasonable way out of a one of the
worst
foreign policy blunders in u.s history
pulling troops out of afghanistan
scaling back in iraq joe biden is
recalibrating
u.s involvement in the region for the
first time in more than two decades
he sees the bigger threat to u.s
national security
coming from cyber attacks and china but
he's been around a long time
and you'll know that while he can scale
back he can't fully take his eye off the
middle
east alan fisher al jazeera at the white
house